welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in ufc broadcaster laura sanko joined
thick boy fight news to give her
exclusive thoughts on the upcoming ufc
paris fight night event when asked about
the fight between middleweight's marvin
vittori and robert whittaker senko said
she believes the pair are at a fork in
the road both have two losses to the
middleweight champion israel adesania
and that makes this a loser goes home
match-up it's always going to be an
important fight in the middle of weight
division but they're both in a tricky
spot having lost to
to izzy you know both of them so
it's a fork in the road for both the
tory and for whitaker the guy who wins
is probably going gonna get another
crack at some point and the guy who
doesn't is i mean gonna stay in the top
five you're always gonna be that guy but
the problem is we've lost the chant
multiple times i mean it's just it's
such a tricky situation so yeah critical
fight for both of those guys for sure
at media day for ufc paris robert
whittaker told reporters that he feels
like he is being underestimated by
marvin vittori whitaker explained that
victoria relies on a brawling approach
and that if he overlooks whitaker's
technical ability he will get caught he
wants to turn it into a dog fight he
wants to turn it into a bar room brawl
that's his fight style get up close push
up against the fence box you up take you
down wear you out that's what he does
i'm very different i'm in out i hit hard
i hit fast i'm technically better than
him i believe i think i'm going to hit
him too much i think i'm going to be too
much for him i think he's
underestimating how good i am how fast i
am how hard i hit and i think that'll
come out on saturday at media day
vittori told reporters that he is
looking to solidify himself as the
number one contender with a win over
whitaker which he believes will be
enough to earn him a title shot
regardless of who the champion is
vittori couldn't help but to take shots
at israel adesania and believes that
alex pereira will defeat him at ufc 282
video courtesy of the mack life yeah i
mean um i don't plan things like that
but like
i want pereira to win just because
it would excites me more
as a next challenger eventually
and i think that will happen
because after this i mean i'm going to
establish myself as number one contender
i mean what's left for me pretty much
for everybody
and um
[Music]
yeah i mean i think it would be it would
be undeniable another title shots with a
great performance against uh whitaker
you know
but if
yeah
yeah i mean like
i decided it's over man i can i
nothing excites me about that guy of
course i'll get my win against him
before
before i'm done with all this but um
yeah man i mean the things that he can
do best now it's paint against nails i
definitely like more pereira
and and and and you know the way he
carries himself and
the way he goes about fighting and all
that like not much not much [ __ ]
just straight
bad [ __ ] kind of type of thing
and
that's it on episode 284 of the weighing
in podcast with josh thompson and big
john mccarthy the pair broke down the
keys to victory for both vittori and
whitaker the
robert whittaker is the faster fighter
he's tighter with his stand up he's got
the cleaner combinations he's more
crafty on the feet
but if i'm going to say really what it
comes down to is it's going to come down
to the toughness of the tory if he's
going to get it done he's got to
pressure the takedowns he's got to grind
on him hang on him make him fight an
uncomfortable fight
robert whittaker on his back foot is not
the same fighter he is going forward not
the same fighter standing in the center
of the cage dictating the pace of the
fight he can sprawl and then prop you
back up and land head kicks and
combinations
but you've but i think if vittori does a
little bit of how he fought izzy by
trying to press him to the fence trying
to control him that way i think he'll
have a little bit more success on
getting whittaker down i don't know if
he can hold him down he can hold him
down is the difference but i think he'll
be able to get him down
now how much will that slow robert
whittaker down on the feet and how much
of an effect will that have during this
duration now it's only a three i think
it's only a three round five
yeah three round fight it's gonna be
very hard to take him down repeatedly in
a three-round fight and take robert
whitaker down
patty pimlett believes that he has an
eating disorder on a recent episode of
stevo's wild ride pimplet said that he
thinks he has an addictive personality
and that while he has overcome other
vices from his youth this one has stuck
i've had party days you know what i mean
i've been bad then i got into gambling a
little and i was bad with that i think
now it's moved on the food i genuinely
think i'm a food addict i think i've got
a bit of an eating disorder because of
mma the weight cuts dieting i genuinely
think i have a bit of an eating disorder
people when they go eat with me they are
visibly shocked at how much i can eat
pimplet shared that he is hoping to
fight on december 10th on a card that is
rumored to feature jon jones no fight on
the schedule but i got my eye on the
december 10th card it's got me excited
to be honest i haven't been excited in a
long time if you share the octagon the
same night as jon jones you're gonna be
excited on a recent episode of the jim
rome show dana white shared that he
believes khabib is legitimately done
with fighting forever when asked white
revealed that he recently talked to the
former lightweight champion about
returning to combat sports in some
capacity but was quickly shut down
khabib's retired it's weird that you
asked me that question i just reached
out to him recently to see if he's
interested in something and he's like
i'm retired brother i'm done i don't
think khabib ever comes back it was
something different i was trying to get
him to do a grappling match he's like
i'm done i'm retired i think that when
his father passed away that was a wrap
for him and he's just focused on
training other guys and helping them
become world champions leon edwards
coach dave lavelle spoke with mma junkie
about possible title challengers for
edwards when asked about the
implications of the nate diaz hamza
shimayev bouts at ufc 279 lavelle said
he believes a win puts chimaya in the
talks for a title shot if he does beat
nate and manages to beat nate in a badly
fashion and retire him i think somehow
they'll be looking to slip him in
somewhere down the line lavelle had some
harsh words for two-time welterweight
title challenger colby covington
covington has been known to call edwards
leon scott suggesting that no one knows
who he is and now lavell is saying
covington must own up to that colby you
little redneck you can stay furthermore
it's his time to talk it's his time to
let these so-called big mouths colby
called him what didn't even call him by
his name what was he calling him leon
scott well i've got news for him now
it's not leon scott call him sir leon
scott from this day on when we get
around to you we'll deal with you mate
tmz sports caught up with the rampage
jackson who gave a former opponent of
his advice jackson believes that jon
jones should take a warm-up fight at
heavyweight before challenging francis
nagano or stipe miocic no cap jon jones
is the best person i ever fought
i don't think i could give him advice
he's a he's a better fighter than me you
know what i'm saying i keep it 100 here
no but the weight but you do know about
the the heavy hitters you know yeah yeah
i i don't i don't know about jon jones
chin it's it's been rumors that
you know saying hello got a strong chin
yeah through the heavyweights man you
know they hit harder but um i feel like
jones is a smart fighter and it was
really hard for me to hit him he
wouldn't he wouldn't let me hit him
granny jones is a dirty fighter when you
get close to him he gonna poke you in
the eye and kick your knee backwards you
know what i'm saying he's a long fighter
but
but uh yeah uh heavyweights
they're different monsters man they hit
hard they'll catch they can catch you
slipping they catch you they catch you
slip and hit you one
look look at francis
yeah
that guy that guy hit you man it's like
lights out game over well so so what do
you what does he do how could he prevent
you know he just got he probably just
had to um take the fight to the ground
and like keep him from hitting him well
he got those sharp ass elbows yeah yeah
he got some slick you have some slick
moves but he hasn't fought in a while
either have it no it's been a minute
yeah so i would say his first
heavyweight fight he should do a warm-up
he shouldn't go in there with the big
boys looking for more original mma
content check out the rest of thick boy
youtube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shop show food truck diaries and
fight night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action